HAOHSIANG LIAO: Whenever you
have interaction with people,
you leave impressions.
You are evaluated.
So that's a very basic,
fundamental idea.
We want to give evaluation to
our students each performance.
That means each class.
And the second thing
is we are convinced
that, as long as students
are persistent and consistent
in their efforts to
take this course,
they can demonstrate very
good skills in Chinese.
So because of those two reasons,
we adopt a daily grading system
here.
So usually, after
class, we provide
feedback to each student's
performance in class--
including language, including
his cultural behavior--
so that students know what to
improve for the next sessions.
We usually do written feedback.
So we use an online-- we have
a website called Engrade.
So besides entering grades,
you can also leave comments
to each student privately.
So each student, as
long as they get access
into their website
to their account,
they will read the comments
from the instructor.
So the comments--
it really depends
on the student's performance.
It can be as simple
as, you know, pay
attention to the
following pronunciations.
It can be a little
bit more elaborated.
For example, think
about, how are you
going to deal with
compliments in Chinese?
For example, this is another
example I always like to use.
In American culture, when
you receive a compliment,
it's very natural for
you to say thank you.
For example, your
Chinese is very good.
You say, thank you.
Your English is good.
Thank you.
However, being humble
is the way when
you receive a compliment
in Chinese culture.
You don't accept it
by saying thank you.
Sometimes you say things,
for example, like,
there's still a long way for
me to go, so it's too far.
Oh, I don't know where the
compliments come from. [LAUGHS]
So yeah, the fundamental
idea in Chinese culture
about compliments
is to remain humble.
So if the student's performance
in class is from his L1,
we will encourage
them and give them
the feedback by
thinking about, how
do you deal with compliments
in Chinese culture,
according to a textbook
where everything
is based on the materials
we cover in class?
So students can know
this is something
that they can work on.